very Pro masculinity I'm very Pro
traditional gender roles and so I
definitely felt that the message was
important and and I wanted to get that
out there you know I'm tired of fem
Centric societies I'm tired of women
being forced into the workplace I'm
tired of women having to rise up and
fill the void that you know all these
feminized men have left you know I guess
in some ways the message was very
personal and was very much in my own
self-interest as well right like I don't
want to be a boss all the time you
know it's not what I want I don't want
that for my daughters my friends don't
want that yeah it was very personal I
want a patriarchy I genuinely do believe
a patriarchy is better than you know
this matriarchy fem Centric world that
we live it